com'è la situazione vabbè se quello che
devo provare per adesso
non ho ancora finito il giro quanto a
mola di moretta
i giornali
la moda
ma non ce l'abbiamo fatta
bello pieno bel bottino
benvenuti in un nuovissimo come tanti di
voi sapranno durante le vacanze sfondata
a new york non ero mai stata quindi ho
visitato tutta la città
ho visitato anche i luoghi le location
delle serie cerchiamo di più e non
vogliono niente dovete andare a vedere
il video che vi lascio qua e o anche
ritagliato del tempo l'ultima giornata
per andare a visitare i negozi perché
anche quelli su militano ovviamente a
parte gli scherzi non ho avuto
tantissimo tempo perché comunque in una
settimana
non mi ricordo abbiamo invitato new york
tutta new york 15 avevo messo un po di
tempo e il tempo per andare a fare
shopping realtà è stato poco quindi mi
sono dovuta focalizzarmi su messa lì con
la mattina dalla cartina mattina e io ho
detto devi concentrarti su pochi posti
ma buoni e quindi visto che comunque a
milano i negozi non mancano sono andata
nei negozi che quando ci sono quindi
forever due to one e top software
nell'intro avrete notato una marina
elettrizzata una marina presa benissimo
una marina folgorata dal bagliore dello
shopping e che io proclamerà
ufficialmente sport agonistico perché
comunque non tutti sanno che non è così
semplice come sembra perché c'è comunque
una grande città gira negozi tutti i
piani provarsi tutta la roba comunque è
uno sport e va rispettato partiamo
subito con il primo acquisto
allora vi posso anticipare che le avete
già viste in particolare in un tic toc
che ho pubblicato di recente e questo
tic toc si vedono tante scarpe se non mi
seguite su tik tok iniziato a seguirmi
mi chiamo anche lì marina ufficio c.so
parentesi queste scarpe mi piacevano da
un sacco di tempo e agli otto ragazzi le
ho trovate a un prezzo stracciato
stracciato sento per oggi chiamando il
numero verde in sovrimpressione potete
acquistare queste scarpe a un prezzo
straccia no
ebbene sì sto parlando dell svela a
quattro sorelle allora qui in italia se
non sbaglio costano sui 100 110 e 119
non mi ricordo a new york le ho trovate
a 55 dollari che in euro sono circa 47
euro
quindi ragazzi cioè o sono tarocche
oppure è è stato un affare
mi sembrano oppure stato un affare non
li ancora messe come potete notare sono
belle bianche candide perché non le
volevo sporcare per il video dopo il
video di oggi le utilizzerò e le sporche
robben e no scherzo allora le fila le ho
acquistate in un negozio di scarpe non
ricordo il nome
mentre tutte queste così lo è qui che vi
sto per far vedere le ho prese da
forever twenty one che un negozio che io
adoro compro spesso
online e new york c'era il negozio
quindi sono subito andata a comprare
qualcosina
partiamo da questa gonna che io
chiamerei canarina canarina perché non
ho mai accarezzato un canarino ma è
morbida e immagino che canarini siano
morbidini e mi piace un sacco 9 donadi
metterla chiaramente adesso non posso
mettere perché è un po callina poi ho
acquistato questo vestito che mi sta
molto non so perché è di gossip girl di
blair e molto stile chanel è chiaramente
è da brava ragazza da cena o pranzo in
famiglia non da discoteca però mi piace
molto e molto classico e molto sobrio
esternamente poi questo qua invece era
in saldo perché faceva parte appunto
della collezione estiva e mi piace un
sacco lo metterò spero adesso se non
prossima estate guardate il filo bollate
che sexy cioè proprio il contrario di
questo marina è questo vestito alla
gossip girl brava ragazza finto chanel e
vestito alla kylie jenner che va in
discoteca a miami
poi questo un po modello un po da nonna
però mi piaceva un sacco il colore e poi
anche questo e morbidissimo e niente
colore proprio da marina quindi mio
questo invece l'oro era fin da subito è
però poi ho detto magari vi sta male e
invece ragazzi addosso mi sta benissimo
cioè mi fa quasi le tette e fantastico e
per finire questo abbiamo avuto il finto
janin co abbiamo il finto versace e
anche questo estivo copre tutto e niente
perché a parte le braccia e lascia un
poco si vedono ma mi piaceva molto
solissimo molto sopra si lo so qui sotto
invece abbiamo il bottino di top shop
non sono però resi di talk show perché
top shop by diciamo brand al suo interno
e ho scoperto
brand di cui mi sono innamorata che si
chiama a un soft london caro come il
fuoco ma dei vestiti delle cose
pazzesche che io qua milano non ho mai
trovato e quindi diciamo mi sono data
alla pazza gioia sempre pronti mi
sentivo di dire pesano 10 kg ecco vi
dico solo che in valigia
al ritorno eravamo carichi come non so
cosa solo per colpa di questi vestiti
partirei subito da lui sensazionale
allora a parte che anche questo mi fa mi
farete perché spinge presta così tanto
che sembro quasi formosa e bellissimo il
colore bellissimo tutto sta vista
proprio cucito addosso perfetto e non
vedo l'ora di metterlo chiaramente avrei
potuto farvelo vedere indossato no però
era troppo troppo ac nella cosa invece
io mi farò aspettare magari l'evento
dove lo indossano propria volta e vi
fossero la foto così vedrete come vista
addosso per avere cielo magari visto
rissi ma non lo so questo frutto ho
sempre della stessa stessa brand
che adoro nero come tutto il mio
guardano a le mani chine come si dice un
po scampanate a farfalla nota come
felice e e forti con così allo scollo
coesi quindi
insomma è più bello da vedere che da
descrivere io mi trovo in difficoltà e
anche questo me lo vedete vedrete che
indossato in qualche foto su in seguito
in su insert marino ufficio e qui
arriviamo al completo che io ho chiamato
kim kardashian palmo gonna tubino bella
aderente che fa le forme anche a chi non
ne ha e top broadsoft con la faccia pure
non so se ce la facciamo proprio un
filino ma comunque se ti alzi la gonna è
praticamente sembra un vestito unico ed
è bellissimo ragazzi che c'è proprio io
vado pazza per questi vestiti così mezzi
intrecciato in un fantastico ultimo
acquisto da top su questa donna sobria
perché nessuno farà causerà capelli una
minigonna rosso semaforo però molto
bella ne ho viste tante in giro così a
new york quindi ragazzi e ragazze compra
una con tipo questa perché sarete subito
moda ultimo acquisto new york l'ho presa
una bancarella
appena l'ho visto mi sono innamorata
sapete quanto io ami la disney non è un
vestito non è non riguarda diciamo
l'abbigliamento ma riguarda il mondo
dell'arte secondo me questa è arte e
infatti l'ho preso adesso devo trovare
la cornice e mapello in camera 4
quanto è simpatico quanto è arte quanto
è top
adoro cioè troppo carino per 20 c'erano
tutti vari può dirti con le principesse
ognuna aveva presentate letta aveva i
gioielli poi c'era quella col telefonino
quindi instagram
poi c'era mi ricordo comunque ognuno
aveva un accessorio qualcosa che insomma
lo rendeva particolare e tutela la
scritta bc place nella serie io sono la
principessa diventto 6
il video hall di new york finisce qui
come avrete notato che mi sono
abbastanza contenuta è però preso tutte
cose bellissime che non vedo l'ora
d'indossare non ho indossato ancora
niente ed è quindi sarete i primi a
vedere i miei outfit di new york su
instagram un applauso in diretta
nazionale a salvo grazie per avermi che
accompagnato in questa sessione di
shopping estremo
io vi malvagia
scusa
[Musica]